today me and the boys are playing among
us with sapnap george and dream three
the largest minecraft youtubers on the
platform let's go
yes let's do it oh my gosh imposter
again
yes me and dream are impossible we're
gonna we're gonna crush everyone we're
going to crush everyone i see stick with
dream and we win i'm going to follow him
around just for the littles the entire
time i'm going to follow trees just
doing my tasks as i'm supposed to
working it out who's it going to be my
plan is to bait people and catch them in
the act all i do is follow dreams leader
it's an easy dub let's go dream team
baby dream freaking team i haven't seen
anyone oh chris didn't seem to want me
yet i hate this one i'm looking at my
screen for too long someone's gotta kill
me wait why is it dark
now i'm going to see if chandler kills
jimmy scanning
oh no double kill right here
gosh
somebody
anybody stop get away
oh
okay listen i'm kind of blind okay i
feel like i'm about to die i need to
catch up with the crew what do you want
to do dream all right the lights are out
oh he's going up here to kill all right
i'm gonna go down here there's gonna be
a dead body in cafeteria i'm gonna die
right here all right
yep
every time vent
about here uh
so i can just stare at this screen and
see stuff dream okay i don't trust her i
really don't trust dreams george george
is my alibi he's chasing me okay please
i need to find someone else i need to
find someone i need to find someone i
need to find someone where are you dream
[Music]
oh oh you i know who's in security right
now tell me tell me tell me tell me i
just got into security mr beast was
there i literally just entered security
no jimmy were you watching cameras i was
but i freaked out when i saw dream run
in and i closed it did you see chris
walk into the room what no oh no i was
positive we were gonna solve this one
because i saw the cameras were on
instead of using information from the
game let's figure out who here hates
chris the most
i'm sad there's a world where it's dream
yeah but i was nowhere near this kill so
if it was an admin i never even went
near you well i just saw you run towards
security from cafeteria yeah why would
he walk up to the security camera if i
was already watching it because
apparently when you're watching it you
don't see when people die jimmy i
panicked i panicked george where were
you george i ran pus security but like
this is the only thing i have to say i
think it's zap then it's up at sap
itself it has to be something i skipped
we can't skip we literally can't carl
this we're not playing by traditional
rules like even if there's two imposters
they're not gonna be good enough if
sharif gets this win it's dream it's
definitely a dream dream is spooking me
out but like i have no reason to to
think it's him other than he was just
chasing me downloading files for four
days
[Music]
get me out of here i don't want to die
i'll just do my tests like a good little
ghost sap nut chandler so some didn't
come in here which is interesting oh
look at that look at that it's all
straight in a row dream
oh don't
don't do it to me surely not mr beast
[Music]
i need to find dream and we need to get
a double kill a sap
come on dream just kill just kill just
kill
kill kill kill kill kill i killed
someone i killed someone oh come on
they must have seen yes
let's go dreamers go crazy easy dumb
easy dog people listen to carl i called
it out if anybody skipped that wasn't
the imposter
you threw that game and you need to
uninstall it i didn't know i didn't know
hey carl i'll uninstall right right now
all right run it back all right i'm not
doing tasks i'm following somebody this
whole game i'm sick of dying first
[Music]
all right finally i'm imposter oh okay
chris we can do this okay detective
sapnap is on the case
someone come into my little
into my kill den come on dude i'm just
gonna do tasks and stop not and be a
happy
george
goodbye stop nap
oh
i'm good come on finish we're gonna lose
to this there's nothing else i can do no
one's gonna find my body no one's gonna
find my body
dream my body's over there they could
just double kill and we could lose and
let's do a report i'm standing report
just in case
chris it was at this moment that he knew
yo you just saw him vain you just saw
him vent he just vented in front of my
eyes i'm running oh did i get away with
it
no way i think i got away with it am i
the greatest that is the question hello
dream i'm safe hello carl i'm safe chris
hopped an event
all right so jimmy i don't know if you
saw what i saw but we walked by chris
who hopped into event i don't know if
you noticed it but we walked by him yes
yes i
you know what i can't even lie i walked
over there to do something and i missed
clicked
get out of here unfortunate oh this is
my first round i also think dream is one
because me and dream did the exact same
task he was doing a task i walked up did
the test walked away and he didn't start
walking away until i did and i have a
feeling he was waiting for me to finish
till he did so i'm just putting it out
there that i think is streaming i just
called out chris for venting i'm gonna
pin it on dream because he killed me
first i'm sorry i didn't mean to let you
down dream uh you got this
yeah okay i'm sure dream called him out
because he knew yeah that other people
saw it maybe yeah
dream didn't want to wait to try to bait
me out of it because he didn't want to
be suspected chris was trying to do a
five-head play by saying dream knowing
that we would be like oh that means
dream's cleared all right i've gotta
sabotage
and do right by it george because i let
him down
this is where george killed me dude he
killed me and left my child alone all
right listen i'm not good enough at this
game to win okay
i am not going to be able to win this
game there's no way
i love spamming doors closed oh i'm
locked in here
i started my task here doors are being
shut this makes things carl i don't know
why it's kind of a pro move to just like
shut all the doors
now i'm making people suspicious all
right so what i'm doing here is i'm
closing doors with a lot of people in
the area so that way they're suspicious
of the people around them they think
it's their friend doing it he locked me
in come on chris
i'm just gonna follow car around and
shut doors in front of his face i think
chris is trying to sabotage stream to
make it look like it's him and it's not
actually him
no no chris yeah chris is messing with
me okay chandler hello you saw me okay
do i just go kill him i think i'm gonna
go kill him oh he's gone he's gone
where did he go
hello where are you
he's locking the doors on me why they
wanted to bring us left therefore
there's probably a body right i want to
head right i bet you george is gonna be
dead over here okay i'm gonna call it
oh look look carl's gonna think it's
jayla yep okay it's georgetown oh i'm
holding true i'm voting dream i don't
care what anyone says
no no no no no no no no i don't i don't
know if it's actually a stream i don't
know if it actually is dream i would
have just killed you then here's the
problem is that there was sabotage
closing the doors with me in a dream to
convince me that dream was the imposter
i don't know if you kept noticing that
dream i don't know like george was the
only one that wasn't by reactor when we
were all there so this kind of stuff but
george what was your task this round uh
i went into navigation and did the
download or upload thingy i did wise
yeah that was sauce we scooped oh you're
sass carl is major sauce how am i sus
cuz he's trying to be my friend and he
knows that the only way he's an imposter
he'll win is he's my friend i said i'm
not proven i'm gonna follow a dream
around if i died him silly fools it's
gogi
no one ever suspects go trying to break
him up distract him i can't get in
carl's gonna kill mr beast and i'm alone
with him he's gonna blame me and then he
wins oh my god kill
25 seconds oh that's so sus that's so
sus he went down
that oh
it's george it's they're gonna catch him
now hey chandler he's watching to see
he totally knows it oh no don't do it to
me oh he's gonna go kill chandler no
run jammer run run i actually think it's
chandler yeah that's so sauce
it's so such that chandler is not going
for this o2 i'm following i'm not gonna
stop following dream he probably is
getting
but i think we just keep playing the
dream and jimmy together and then get
our tasks done okay i need to do
something now there's no one here is
everyone just sitting in the middle
where are these people
they know it's george
no it's george
hello there
oh
it has to be george
tell me where you were i'm on the gas
can right now filling it up you're at
the gas can oh my god wait dream's out
it couldn't have been dreams yeah me and
carl were tail and dream like crazy and
then no there's no chance there's no
chance that george just walked in but
it's not me own guy and just stepped all
over dream's body to get wait was the
body in electrical i'm voting george
this is georgia no no no no listen this
is george i ran in and then carl runs
down and then suddenly the round's over
was was the body right there yes no it
was called did you do the wires in
electrical george no i ran up and then
it was the round ended george george
tell me what you did before you went in
there though i went to the cameras and i
was just checking i was seeing if anyone
was gonna kill someone in front of me
and they didn't and i ran around a bit
no
heck no i'm voting george because i know
what you did george but you didn't do
what you said he killed he killed dream
and tried to walk into electrical to
vent out didn't know that we were there
that's what happened unless it's carl
all right either either it's george or
carl's lying and we just handed carl the
dog i'm sorry george
i'm sorry
i'm not good enough to win on my own i
was like oh there's george that it's a
dead body pop top and i was like that's
a coincidence i was like i was like yo
you your feet have to be bloody like
there's no chance you just miss the body
thank you everybody for watching hit
that subscribe button we'll see you in
the next video